all right first we got some relationship
advice for Cory beam from Westminster
Maryland see being out of West many old
court B oh yeah Roger copy Oh what's up
Brandon showers I'm gonna crotch view
seeing a little lumpy bumpy at the
bottom yeah no nation big world need
some relationship advice
Danny 38 year old woman I'm 26
mmm she's got two little ones a nine
year old son your daughter we've been on
and off about two years and things are
going great I love her to death and I
want to be with her forever but you
fight knowing you sometimes about our
age if she feels insecure and because
the guy should be with someone younger
and my age but I don't want that I want
to be with her so I just need help more
now I show her that and how I can just
let her know I love her I don't want to
be with her
thanks guys Gang Gang buzz buzz crotch
bulge o CB huh buzz buzz - you did game
and I've been on a CB radio before and
that crotch bulge that's the closest
thing I've ever been to since then man
they said number two that ham radio you
mean like record breaker
44 and it's somebody come over to house
and try to molest you some trucker oh no
I don't know we had a guy uh me and this
dude Michael and he was all slicked up
in a jowls his mouth was real damp just
like that waiter wet you know what yeah
he had that freakin yeah sticky lips
just living just had a damn watering
hole right in the middle of his face you
know and uh some guy came off we met him
on the ham radio CB and he came over and
um dude we're sitting in his truck bro
in this guy's truck and he was putting I
remember he was seeing how many tootsie
rolls minis the minis we could fit in
our mouths right and Michael's uh some
guy was making love to Michael's mom who
was you know she was a substitute
teacher but he cannot beat the guy's ass
dude yeah cuz the guy was gonna take us
to like it the guy was telling he's
gonna take us to Florida and stuff this
guy was gonna probably murder us or
whatever hell yeah that boyfriend's
awesome yeah although he's banging your
friend's mom whatever substitute teacher
pie not a lot of
money in the bank but sounds it has a
good dude hey guys he was gonna start
with tootsie rolls then end up with his
dick yeah sounds like he saved you guys
well I'm grateful Michael it could fit
almost 14 minis in his mouth how did you
fit
I would probably stopped at about 6 or 7
I got nervous because of my airway I bet
so Michael was just he didn't care about
his Airways didn't care if he knew more
deep though he didn't care if he met the
Lord that afternoon I don't think what
yeah dude and thankfully it took so long
because then that guy came out and beat
that dudes suit teacher what a hero
Clint was that guy's name shutter click
the slit but with like a n in it what
the guys question I'll just age
different yeah he's he's younger than
he's 26 his girl's 38 with two kids dude
it sounds like he is that that young
energy he's trying to do all this [ __ ]
he's trying to jump on YouTube he's
Netflix and chill and and go to [ __ ]
Six Flags and do all this and listen to
little nas acts you're too much you got
the young energy take her to a park read
a book go to Barnes & Noble maybe some
bingo whites watch Philadelphia and talk
to I'm saying no I don't man I watched a
notebook and then discuss it over tea
what are you saying did you hear his
statement yes he loved a woman well she
believes that maybe he's too young for
her and he should find somebody his own
age that's what I'm saying so old and up
bro no you don't start start hanging out
in the Sun so your face looks older oh
yeah maybe dye your hair why again
yeah dye your hair white dude complain
talkers stand in the yard and go like
this all the time
stare out of the front of her yard and
make sure no one's stepping on if they
do you [ __ ] yell at him yeah in a
lawn chair yeah get some graham cracker
op a couple n bombs during dessert got a
jabra you gotta give out coins during
Halloween yeah
oh dude here's the thing she might be
trying to lead you away dude if she's
saying you got to go find somebody
younger that's what I'm think that means
she has that old long dick game waiting
for why she's a longer silver fox
waiting for and maybe I like it but this
guy sounds kind of a dolt it doesn't
sound like he needs to be babysat it
sounds like he's ready to go he's fired
up yeah I know yeah he seems super
mature he senses a video from his
[Laughter]
what do you think Garrett I think I'm
agree with what you feel I think she's
looking for a George Clooney brochure no
offense but she just she's not into it
man
yeah too much she's not into it she's
challenges who why would you tell her
I'm younger don't bang young girls yeah
go bang young girl dude should I be a
freak though those older girls are free
well yeah but that isn't we gonna do
with this Brendon underdog you sustain
the fat sigh he might be Dana reacts
well she might want him to [ __ ] younger
chicks and tell her about it
she does that over a matinee movie you
know I'm saying no I don't know what
you're gonna hook up with old Shady oh
yeah with her killer yeah we hang on the
banging on the door her kids were
banging on the door yeah they're like my
mom she's like we all watch TV for five
minutes yeah D over here's just balls
deep in my mom oh I got dark how old
were you look 17 how old was she like 29
Wow I pass yeah but that was at the time
that was like do you feel any remorse
about an hour no no I think the daughter
was gonna be fine because she when she
did open the door she was like mom I
just wanted some juice like she was so
calm about it like this happens all the
time I see this daughter's gonna be fine
where'd you meet this older lady yet uh
my dad used to work there like though
you know he drops off like chips and
snacks for gas stations in the morning
like you know some people he told me
that there was this hot girl that we're
doing and so I was like you know my dad
always thoughts about this guy so I'll
pull it in she was in there
started holler at her and then a [ __ ]
I I thought it my dad drops the [ __ ] off
she's like oh I like that guy and that
was it man yeah I know
do you keep in touch with the kids or
with the woman no no it was it was after
that night we never spoke again just the
bad times the one one time old lady hit
her yeah how and how long ago was that
if we fund the kids right now what age
you need the kids would be are we
talking I'm 29 we're talking 12 years
man and hell where the kids at that
point they were all like eight nine just
kiss oh we could call one of the kids
you like hey do you remember
isn't listening like Oh a young Morgan
Freeman it's all time with us Morgan
Freeman [ __ ] our mom nope dude a buddy
of mine said that Sinbad hooked up with
his mom when he was a kid and let them
narrow left a pair of orange pants at
his house true story I'm here in Gary
Indiana
I can send bad dude hopping loads
leaving orange pants and sing good huh
yeah soon right yeah brother let's get
out of this we got what we even doing
giving her advice our that we're given
the the dick camera dude advice on his
older girl it to me it sound like maybe
she don't really want to be in it but
she looking for a George Clooney in your
yeah your little Nozick you're a Bobby
clowny you know yeah but not in a bad
way you're just young man
and looked at things on a ripen fast
brother she's leaving her a dad bro well
she's I mean maybe the guy can provide
he looks like he could work every Wells
Fargo or somebody's probably an
entry-level position so I don't know man
I would ask somebody who probably he
[ __ ] knows Brenda yeah me too I last
sewing a little more into the game as
you're dealing with some heavy
repercussions here kids
401 K yeah yeah what are you gonna do do
when the kid starts doing ministration
or whatever and you got to have a chat
with them and you you don't know [ __ ]
yeah you don't know [ __ ] do you still
play and I'll you know call a duty or
whatever you can play a fortnight when
the kids run do the homework yeah just
those days goodbye bro you ain't ready
you're ready she smells it what else
back up my broccolini get your life
together
I'm not touching